this is a production of cornell
university
welcome everybody to to season three of
the cornell terp show
uh this thing started uh back in 2020 as
a as really an outlet for frank and i to
talk into the void to feel like we were
talking to somebody
um but we've gotten such great feedback
from our live audience the people that
watched it on youtube or listened to it
as a podcast
so we're really excited to bring back
season three
every year we're trying to get better
and our theme is the fastest 30 minutes
in turf we want to get you guys in here
uh get you a bunch of information to you
timely information
and a compact time frame and get you out
of here quickly so
thank you guys for sticking with us
for anybody new listening
my name is carl scamenti i'm an urban
environmental scientist here at cornell
and joining me my co-host is dr frank
rossi
associate professor in the plant science
department here he's director of
agriculture science major now and he's
our turf grass extension specialist for
the state of new york so um happy to be
with you thanks for coming back first
third season
our thursday shows are going to be kind
of golf focused
and our friday shows will flip-flop
between
lawn and landscape and sports turf um so
we'll have a couple segments for you
uh every show and uh i'll start us off
here like i did
uh last year with um on our golf show a
bmp second carl you're going too fast
brother you're going too fast we're
getting started we're working out the
kinks here with me and so uh
carl let me just duel and i'm going to
bring you back because i'm going to
embarrass you in front of everybody and
the good thing about this uh that we've
noticed is we're always happy to have
folks here and have a conversation and
carl's right we were i think we needed
an outlet to speak into the void and
also that you know you feel like you
want to do something i think you get
into this line of work uh as as a matter
of service so for those of you
uh listening on the podcast or listening
watching it as a recording uh it also
works at 1.25 and 1.5 speed and then 30
minutes does go faster carl so with that
let me thank uh the met superintendents
association and the long island golf
course superintendent association for
not only the long time support of our
turf grass program uh but also the uh
support of this particular uh madness
that carl and i are in on so so as carl
said you remember when this thing
started out it was you know let's just
help each other a little bit things are
bad for everybody uh how do we make it
okay and i want to give you some numbers
as a good scientist i went and did some
calculating on these things we're
starting our third season we've done 54
shows to this point it's at about a half
an hour each it's 27 hours of education
of course because we go faster than 30
minutes it's likely actually less we've
had 43 guests from 17 states carl and i
have been completely nuts talking to
people from all over the country and
thank you all very much for 11 000
views now that's not as much as the turf
nut gets to spread pigment and sand on
his lawn but we're gonna be happy for it
anyway
uh let me get to my next slide okay so
um you know i always used to like to put
a picture of uh something to make a
smile uh this happened to me last week
this made me smile uh these are my uh
former graduate student colleagues at
the university of rhode island island
this is uh randy vanyares here on the
right runs to catholic cemeteries
in new york city and of course many of
you probably know professor scott abden
at stockbridge i was a graduate student
for dick skogley after scott and scott
was there after randy so this was a nice
little thing that happened in rhode
island and honestly it felt really good
to get uh back together in groups of
people and as long as the cdc says this
is okay uh i for one uh i i kept saying
i'm so happy to see people i'm even
happy to see people i don't like
so with that here's my i'm going to
introduce my colleague here who did who
didn't give himself enough credit for
his new position in our program as the
urban environmental specialist coming
from a long time period of coordinating
our state park golf course project uh
carl last golf season uh won the new
york state mid-amp so this was a big
deal uh of course right and and i'm
going to embarrass him and tell him also
he's been my colleague on this really
important project that i will run the
slides carl and you run us through the
bmp tip of the day
yeah the um so this project frank you're
talking about uh our friends at the new
york state pollution prevention
institute
up at the rit rochester institute of
technology we partnered with them and
really trying to get golf courses to
adopt bmps um and it's been a three-step
process we're in our third year of this
now
the first year was about
measuring that adoption so randomly
surveying a bunch of golf courses in our
region getting data and then based on
that data step two is outreach and
education and so we did this last year
on our turf shows
a bmp tip of the day um so we're still
in this step two outreach and education
period
um and we're using this infographic
poster that we've created so a really
kind of smooth streamlined way of
looking at bmp's
par birdie eagle right pars or things we
think everybody should do should be
doing birdies and eagles kind of that
next level um so one of the pars is is
uh in our water section managing water
is looking for leaks and i know we
haven't turned on our irrigation systems
yet this year and the leaks are coming
out of the ground right it's it's
leaking everywhere it's sloppy and
we're getting the snow melted off but
soon enough you're going to be starting
the irrigation
systems up uh and just getting out there
and looking at the heads running around
um is really informative so i got a
chance to do this at a couple golf
courses last year now we did an
irrigation on it where we get this
really cool data and what i'll say is is
when you see a head that is obviously uh
throwing incorrectly whether it's
throwing too low or it's not rotating
the same speed as the other heads
it shows in the data so this is an
example of just
us kind of putting this data together on
a certain green
and you can see that head a up there in
the top left
applying almost two times the the amount
of water as other areas of of the green
and and that head was throwing a little
bit low i wouldn't say i would have said
oh yeah it's two times as much water low
but um i think that's the cool thing
about matching the data to what you
observe
and in this case had c and d those two
front heads uh just the topography of
the green was was what is throwing off
the uniformity there so
those heads were working fine just say
hey run those heads a little bit longer
but
looking for leaks when you see something
wrong with the head i can guarantee you
it's gonna show up in in your uniformity
and that extends throughout the season
so i know we don't we're not watering
yet you guys probably don't want to see
water for another three months but let's
get it in your head uh just just take a
trip around when you first start up that
irrigation system and prioritize this
stuff early and carl i'll just add that
was great and i'll just add this is
enormously insightful to get data right
consistent with our theme about
data-driven management right and this is
a really good indication but one of the
things you mentioned we just want to
reinforce and you'll probably come back
to it is we got to waste till we got a
water because the sun's not that very
high in the sky right if you look at the
sun governing the amount of water we're
going to use we're a little ways you can
feel it warming a little bit and it gets
the juices going but we're a long way
from even drying out uh never mind the
et levels so thanks a lot carl and let
me uh since we are talking about drying
out and weather i had the pleasure of
being in rhode island last week for the
new england uh regional turf foundation
show as you saw it was sort of old home
week for me i hear all people with more
screwed up accents than i got which
always makes me happy i lived in rhode
island for four years so i know what a
screwed up accent sounds like to all my
rhode island brothers and sisters that
might listen to this and one of the
things i did michelle decosta professor
michelle decosta
from the university of massachusetts led
a
a round table discussion around winter
injury and i'll talk a little bit about
the minnesota project that everybody's
collaborating on uh across the northern
areas as i get into this but one of the
and it was really just a listening
session which many of you know for me
not the easiest thing to do but i
actually did it pretty well stayed quiet
jeff carlson told me for almost 15
minutes before i said something and what
i heard the superintendent say was this
was a roller coaster year and of course
this of course is the greatest roller
coaster in the history of the world the
cyclone at coney island in brooklyn
so let's look at what that roller
coaster temperature looked like the
thing you got to keep in mind and this
starts to get cumulative now right the
earth is warming significantly and we're
starting to really feel the impacts of
that and in really short and a really
you know way to think about it is warm
air holds more water warm air holds more
water so as we warm there's just going
to be more water coming up and around
now that doesn't mean you're not going
to have dry spells so let's start with
temperatures
the september november period the fall
period
the record warmest for minimum
temperatures and almost the record
warmest for the ever period we've
recorded in these few three months
then you look at december and you see
the same trend continuing in the
northeast and of course really bad in in
in the texas central part of the country
now that january comes so so so we're up
and now we're down right now we're down
and and you can see january
started to rank uh quite a bit below
normal you know you're in the top 25
percent coldest januaries we've ever had
uh february now you start to see
the effect that just one cold month
right is is not going to really have
that much of an impact and now we're
starting to see already
record warm temperatures but not so much
the minimums but now the maximums are
coming up a little bit typically we
associate the warming world with a
increase in the minimum temperatures not
necessarily that it's going to get
particularly hotter although it is
getting particularly hotter in places
like india
and and death valley where they're
starting to record temperatures in the
140 range which becomes uninhabitable
for human beings right so so here we are
it's february nice and warm we're only a
couple of weeks into march and it's
sloppy right so what does it look like
moving forward temperature wise the noaa
outlook indicates near normal and you
look at our more refined northeast
climate center predictions and we're in
a longer period we're saying we're
likely to be above normal temperature so
looks like we're going to be warming a
little bit
right the degree day forecast seems to
indicate at base 50 that we're going to
get about 10 to 15 everywhere north of
long island right once you get south of
long island and except for the higher
altitudes you get down into the delmarva
region you're starting to get you know
40 to 50 growing degree days so you're
going to see a big acceleration
in the growing season the further south
you are and you can really see that
demarcation where the cold temperatures
still dipping down from the north right
the trough
in the in the jet stream is bringing
that cold air down and we're going to
stay a little bit
on the cooler side even though the
forecast says overall we're going to be
warmer the two in soil temperatures and
i was glad to see this because i looked
at this a couple of days ago we're
having some problems with our forecast
modeling page so hopefully you'll check
back in the meantime do what i did go to
gdd tracker and we'll talk about that a
little bit later but a lot of these maps
are working pretty good the seed head
map not so good um i was noticing just a
couple of days ago the temperature in
the middle of long island where i chat
with people routinely was uh look on
this map like it was still in the upper
30s and i shot a note down to andy and
mike at that very famous golf course on
long island and and they said oh we got
52 degrees so
uh as of uh yesterday uh it seems to be
uh resonating that you're starting to
see you're getting into the 50 degree
range
now this is starting to feel like an
early spring because the thing that i
always like to keep in mind is you know
in a two inch step the soil does a lot
of buffering of air temperature right
once it gets warm
right if it keeps getting wet it'll
probably stay on the cool side but once
it gets warm it's and it it starts to
get warm the sun keeps coming up that's
where you're really going to see an
acceleration to the growing season now
let's get back to the weather over the
winter and talk about moisture because
this is a perfect lead-in to the
discussion of winter problems moving
forward so here we are october to
december on the left right for those of
you watching on the podcast or obviously
listening on the podcast you know you
look at central new york from syracuse
over to rochester you've got this
enormously wet period but pretty much
normal even dry around the new york
metropolitan area right now you see in
the december the february period it's
starting to get a little drier across
the board
at least as it looks here now when you
look at how this is shaken out i was a
little bit surprised to see this because
it has felt a little bit wetter well
look where i live where i live it's
right in the center of the biggest wet
spot i i i'm confident there's an
atmospheric river over where we live but
when you get into central pennsylvania
harrisburg into the hudson valley orange
county into the connecticut river valley
and especially to the five people that
live in northern vermont right it's
going to be really dry it's been really
dry the further north you get now the
burlington area looks like it's done
pretty well but a lot of the adirondack
park has been a bit on the dry side
right long island is really split down
the middle you get closer to the city
and it's indicating it's on the dry side
and the further out you get this period
looks like it's been a little bit on the
wet side so again moisture tends to be
uh very site specific with the way we're
able to take this data and climate
change is doing it so what about uh just
the week we just came from
well most people
uh got a little bit of rain but along
the coast got a little bit more a little
bit over an inch particularly on the
east end of long island out into the
cape
uh rhode island the bunch of rain fell
out there over the last six days
and you can see now when you look at
precip minus evapotranspiration
most of the northeast right now
is in an excess right and and you know
you look along the coast of jersey where
atlantic city is delaware the delmarva
area especially along the coast some
very wet conditions and actually pretty
dry
not dry not pretty dry but just a little
bit drier as you get north but overall
plenty of moisture in the system and the
outlook is favorable for more moisture
right so this is not uh what everybody
wants to hear but particularly if you're
trying to get some work done okay
moisture
what happens to it when it's cold
now we're on the outside of this now so
a lot of this could be retrospective but
again that that round table discussion
that michelle led professor de costa led
the other day was uh really insightful
and so we're going to take a couple of
minutes here we normally have a guest
and i'm going to draw on
things i've been thinking about for 30
years and talk about winter injury here
so the first thing is uh you know you
got to keep in mind with winter injury
is
if you have moisture
that creates a layer of ice
now there's different kinds of ice
but the simplest way to think about this
and what everybody sweats is
you got a lot of ice
and it sits on there for more than 25 to
30 days
something's gonna happen
this is the big uh what's going to
happen well here's what i promise you if
it's there for 60 days the po is going
to be dead
if it's
and you're probably going to see a 30
percent reduction in bank grass as well
depending on the variety dave miner did
this work many years ago at iowa state
making thick sheets of ice in the middle
of iowa in the 90s so so a lot of old
work tells us essentially
you're suffocating the grass and if you
can get cracks in the ice
um you can help it now here's the
dilemma this came up in the round table
should i go out and air fry should i
take the snow off should i take the
moisture right look at this picture
here's a person going out with a shovel
taking it off i mean
how much damage do you do
doing this now i saw somebody on twitter
the other day i should have thrown it in
here spreading black sand with a
snowmobile
right driving across back and forth the
green with snow and ice on it throwing
snow throwing throwing dark material
because as the sun comes up if it cracks
and gets you a little bit of air in
there
you're solving some of your problem
if
ice encasement and anoxia right lack of
oxygen is your problem now what's more
likely happening is what they're
studying in minnesota
uh
they're studying in minnesota where
what's happening over the course of the
winter and when does grass die
does it die in december january and what
are the environmental conditions
under these winter blankets ice open
whatever it is and they've developed a
monitoring system and here's a picture
of gary deeter's work at the university
of minnesota research plots on the right
where he's actually holding ice and
making ice
on top of the ground and you'll see
these poles in a lot of these slides
that's all part of the people
cooperating across the northern part of
the north america you can see they've
got people well up into british columbia
up into up into edmonton and alberta
alberta province it's you know and
obviously a lot of people in the central
midwest and also we've got a bunch of
folks uh throughout new york state uh
and new england so obviously a wide
reaching product big coup coop project
big kudos to the minnesota folks uh for
pulling this together and everybody else
for stepping up and the golf super
tenants for stepping up so here's a
picture from kevin frank one of the
cooperators of michigan state literally
24 hours apart
literally 24 hours apart so this
actually
is the thing
most people have to worry about because
these what we call in technical terms
incipient freeze thought periods right
these free start periods where it goes
up and down and up and down right you
get these pools right where water
freezes and thaws when open water
when open water is hit by direct
sunlight
it has a greater capacity once it's
heated to hold on to that heat right
now in some ways you'll notice this in
grass way ditches along the side of the
road a lot of times they're the first
thing to green up you're like how the
hell can that be you'll also see this in
compacted soils huh how the hell can
that be because those bodies are able to
get the sunlight
get the heat and hold it right
so they hold it which means they
transfer it into the ground
then into the grass and guess what
happens the grass breaks dormancy
so this is the rub so you can go like
this and you can wake up and you see
where the water was and you got dead
grass so these freeze thought periods
the best way to think about this was
some work done back in the 90s
by jim ross and the group out at the
prairie turf grass research center right
they had annual bluegrass biotypes you
know everything there's no one person's
annual bluegrass is like another right
so they had four biotypes one of them
was the perennial type from the
minnesota breeding program back in the
day i think they call it true putt
nowadays so he got three bio four bio
types it so and these plants were
completely hardened off
before they were exposed to these
temperatures okay so they were perfectly
hardened off until they got 39 degrees
fahrenheit for 24 hours or 39 degrees
fahrenheit for 48 hours or 46 degrees
fahrenheit for 24 hours or 46 degrees
fahrenheit for 48 hours and for those of
you watching here on news channel 8 you
can see
that
it takes about 48 hours at 46 degrees
fahrenheit
to significantly lose
your low temperature hardiness right i
mean yeah it's got to get down to one
degree three degree but there's one
biotype
if it gets to 17 degrees it'll kill it
right it'll kill 50 of the population so
it's the breaking of dormancy that's
leading to the problems uh that's
ultimately causing the damage now so
where does this happen so here's a grass
plant again if you're listening on the
podcast i got a grass plant here and now
i'm pointing at the crown the base of
the plant at the base of the plant there
are crown cells those cells either
differentiate themselves into leaves or
differentiate themselves into roots and
typically what happens is the root cells
die
right so the root cells get killed
in an annual bluegrass plant which means
when the water's there it starts to
green up and produce leaves but as soon
as it dries out a little bit
the root the lack of any rooting leads
to the death of the plant right so what
you're doing
is
seeing now what happens at the cellular
level so we're doing a deep dive here
how does this happen
cells have water
right
they use water to grow
when they're
when they're hardened off and acclimated
to winter they reduce the amount of
water in that cell because they're not
growing they don't need the water
pressure to push the cell to grow so
they inherently have less water that's
available for freezing
but what does happen is water starts to
freeze in between the cells
usually around bacteria usually around
some kind of microorganism that lives
inside the plant starts to crystallize
and then draws water out of the cells
this is what's known as crown hydration
damage when you hear people say crown
hydration that's what they're talking
about now ultimately you see there are
some differences obviously in this
picture you see the annual bluegrass
predominately on the bluegrass fairway
completely dead you see the bluegrass
rough on the right completely alive and
now you know how much bent grass you
have on your putting green because all
the annual bluegrass is dead
we have occasionally seen big
differences in mowing heights typically
you see more damage on lower than higher
but in my opinion species makes a much
bigger difference than mowing height
covers
this is uh a strategy used in a lot of
places impermeable covers how does this
work the beauty of this technique is it
keeps the water out and to keep the
water out look what you got to do you
got to dig those sides of the cover in
so that the water can't get underneath
and get trapped under there because then
you're screwed now there's many
different kinds of covers right
impermeable covers with like a a foam
insulation that separates the cover
creates a little air layer and or like
bubble wrap that like a pool cover now
both of these things are trying to
simulate fluffy snow
that provide that air insulation
underneath the cover
where no moisture is getting in so
courses that have adopted this strategy
and and have figured out when to put
them on how to do it when to take them
off because ultimately you got to get
them off you know you take them off
they're really green you get 10 degrees
the grass looks even worse than it when
it was when you started so this is not
just oh let me try these covers it's let
me get a system to see if this takes
some of the crapshoot
out of trying to get these plants
through the wintertime all right carl as
i wrap up and maybe you got a couple of
questions for me i'll just remind a lot
of guys are thinking about seed head
stuff
the gdd tracker is saying whoa man we're
close
here's on the left you see proxy primo
we're in the target zone looks like
we're going to be for a week
embark for those of you still holding on
to some embark
uh you still got a little bit of time
and you know i'll just remind you you
know for again if you're looking at this
you can see the difference between
treated and untreated
oftentimes you still have seed heads in
treated conditions but when you don't
have seed heads
can suppression oh it looks pretty bad
and looks pretty bad for a long time
now the cornerstone of seed head
suppression these days now has moved to
a fall application and here's some data
from sean askew showing that that winter
spring application
uh is show look at the amount of seed
head suppression from proxy you also get
quite a good seed head suppression
adding the winter only you can also see
embark works pretty good good in the
spring better than proxy if you still
got some i'm a big fan of embark um and
again at the end of the day the proxy
fall
and spring application you know you're
getting
90 suppression when it with a spring app
so don't worry about timing go crazy
because you're already locked in for
some pretty good suppression with just a
fall out
now i'll leave you with this point
because maybe some of you are itching
to get your crabgrass control out there
and all i'll tell you is what my pal
randy i had got to have dinner with him
up in rhode island early on early gone
is his favorite line the sooner you put
this crabgrass material on the more
likely you're probably going to have to
come back and retreat
because the crabgrass pressure is moving
well into july and august okay carl how
are we doing
we're doing great that that was a great
uh review of really winter damage frank
and i hear you categorizing these as two
things we talked about this the other
day
uh physical ice forming on the green and
suffocating the grass that's one but
what i hear you saying is the bigger
risk of injury is that the roller
coaster sort of weather that we get
freezed off freestyle that's the biggest
risk of injury ice forming in literally
the plant with this crown of hydration
um so i i don't like that i heard you
say that this is a roller coaster year
uh between last fall being kind of warm
did the plants harden off very well this
spring kind of having this heavy
precipitation okay we're going to get
warm maybe we'll freeze
so i'm thinking about okay people are
going to start having to to find
management solutions for
this freeze thaw cycle how do i get
basically how do i keep water
off of the green so that it doesn't kind
of uh get into the crown you mentioned
covers as an option surface drainage i
think is something we got to mention
right and have you seen strategies of
people i've seen kind of a trough where
they sod cut something through the green
as a channel to remove water
what do you think about trying to
promote surface drainage as a way to
prevent this it's everything honestly
you know you look at especially the old
golf courses that didn't really rely on
any
um
you know internal drainage because there
wasn't such things at the time they
always relied on on surface drainage so
so um and all these things you've
mentioned um over time things change uh
and i'll also say
um a lot of times the biggest issues are
these bird bats you just get these
little areas where it's just a slight
depression and and you know i've seen
people go to the extent of drilling and
boring a hole and old push-up power
greens boring a hole down literally
three four feet and leaving it open for
the winter so you're exactly right carl
some strategy
of minimizing persistent moisture
that is then available to either uh
freeze and stay frozen or warm and then
freeze uh is is is really the way to
i've always felt like
it's the only really thing you can try
to do uh but i'll say this
you go out further west
bill's talking about desiccation
so you may have a high green that
doesn't get snow covered that does
affect that doesn't get that and then
you got the other problem which is all
the water gets sucked out
yeah right bill's found you can't really
maintain
uh soil moisture in some uncovered
conditions so i don't want to leave
people with the thing that this is the
only way grass dies in the winter these
are the things we're worried about
currently in the northeast right now i
got to tell you it didn't look like a
bad snowmobile year we're going to come
back and maybe have a snowmobile guest
or some discussion about what's going on
with snowmobile uh in a couple of future
shows but
any other questions because you know 30
minutes we're right at the 30-minute
mark uh one of our attendees said that
they used covers to very very good
success and and that's certainly a way
to go it just takes that you got to have
the labor right and a lot of courses out
there don't so
like you said moisture management is key
frank and whether it's in you know we
talked about irrigate you know looking
at your your irrigation heads earlier in
the show we're talking about uh drainage
now that really is a key
across the season so
with that i think we'll wrap it here uh
episode one season three the cornell
turf show in the books uh we'll see you
guys tomorrow we'll have uh uh dr arc de
cayetano of the national
of the uh northeast regional climate
center on he'll give us kind of a
rundown of some some cool weather stats
from the winter you'll hear from a real
weather person not me you know i play a
weather person on tv that's correct
everybody see everybody have a good one
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu